[موسيقى]
مساء الخير الدكتور سليمان الضيقان الفنان
الذي ولد وفي فمه ملعقه من موسيقى تنقلنا
في الحلقه السابقه عبر مشوار والده غنام
الديدان المسيره التي اسهمت في ترسيخ هويه
الموسيقى الكويتيه اما الليله فنتحدث عن
الطفل والشعب الذي ترعرع في هذا البيت
الموسيقي وادرك في سن مبكره شغفه الكبير
بالفن وتغذت حواسه بكافه الانغام
والايقاعات التي صيغه امامها وقرر ان يكمل
المسيره لكن بطبيعه الخاص اوجه التشابه
كثيره بين سليمان الابن والاب غنام
فكلاهما يغرفوا من نهر الموسيقي التراث
لكن سليمان الذي التحق بالمعهد العالي
للفنون الموسيقيه في الكويت عام 87 وحصل
على شهاده البكالوريوس ثم نال عن رسالته
صياغه حديثه للحام مارونيه درجه الماجستير
من جامعه الروح القدس في لبنان ليتبعها
بشهاده الدكتوره عبر رسالته بناء معاصر
للالحان الكويتيه كان له شغف ابعد واكثر
انشغالا بالموسيقى كعالم المستقل عن
الهويات المحليه كان من اللحظه الاولى
يحلم بقياده الاوركسترا وان يطلق عالم
الموسيقى المحليه بايقاعاتها وجذورها
الاصليه للفضاء الارحب نحو العالميه انشغل
بها كلغه لغه وحاله وهويه مستقله بذاتها
وقد كان له ما اراد وبالصعوبات والعقبات
التي تقف عاده امام كل مبدع استثنائي غربه
في المحيط قابليه اقل من المتلقين لهذا
النوع من الاعمال حالته من النبويه لا تجد
صدادها لدى الاجهزه والمؤسسات الرسميه
فكان اول خليجيين يقدم عملا اوبراليا في
دار الاوبرا المصريه العريقه ويلامس
الجمهور والنخبه انطلاقا من قاعدته
الراسخه للموسيقى سحرها ولغتها الخاصه
القادره على الدك كل الحصول وعبوري كل
الاب
قدم ضيفنا عشرات الاعمال الموسيقيه
البومات الموسيقيه مستقله موسيقى تصويريه
للافلام والمسلسلات عروض اوركستراليه
نادره ولافته وجديده في مضمونها وطريقه
عرضها ولا يتوقفوا لحظه واحده عن التاليف
عالم من الموسيقى في المقابله هذا المساء
مع الموسيقار الكويتيه الدكتور سليمان
الديدان فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
دكتور اسامه
الحكام ولد في فمه ملعقه الذهب يبدون
الدكتور سليمان ولد وفي فمه ملعقه من
الموسيقى امتدادا اللي غناهم الديك كمان
هذا الموسيقي الاستثنائي في تاريخ في
تاريخ الكويت بشكل عام كيف اثرت عليك هذه
المساله او كيف ساهمت في في صناعه هو
ولاده ايه يا اسلام اذا انا رجعت لي
الذاكره او تكوين يعني ذاكرتي في ذاك
الوقت من وانا صغير كنت اشوف والدي
كموسيقى يمكن ما كنت عارف الحجم الموسيقى
او يعني عموما يعني اهميه الموسيقى في في
المجتمع بس انا كنت في ذاك الوقت
حضرت تكوينه لبدايه يعني ابتكار الموسيقي
فاسمع يمكن انه يعزفها في العود وبعدين
يمكن بعد فتره اسمها في التلفزيون او
اسمها
الفكره تبدا وبعدين تكبر كنت تشوف المنتج
بشكل
التكوين نفس الوقت همم من حسن الفرس
حضرت مع اكبر شعراء اللي كان يعني يمكن
كتب معه يعني كتبوا مع والدي الاعمال ان
كان همم بكل اشكال ان كانت تراثيه ولا
شعبيه او فصحه حضر طبعا عن بدر بروس لي
اشياء كثيره
فكنت وانا صغير جدا صغير يعني فاحضر لهم
وهم في تكوينهم في اي عمل من العمال فكنت
اخذ افكار واحضر واتنصت يعني مع المرحوم
مبارك الحديبي مع الشهيد فايق عبد الجليل
مع شعرك كثار هنتكلم عن السبعينات يعني
انت مواليد 70 بدايه السبعين فكنت انا
اذكر ان انا كنت احبي وحتى وانا احبي يعني
احمي كانت تقول والدتي
يقول لها والدي والوالده همم شيء سليمان
كنت صغير وبعدين انا يمكن في عمري اربع
سنوات خمس سنوات انا عندي رباب وكامل فك
انت حاول اتخبى وراء اي همم يعني كنبه ولا
شهوه جديد فكان يسمعوني من صوت ههه خلاص
لحظه اللي شعراتك تعلقت بهذه البيئه بهذا
المجال تحديث
اعتقد من البدايه لان هذا يمكن حسن ادخل
دارك كان داخل غارت علي بابا كلها كنوز
الات موسيقيه كتب افتح كتاب وانا ما اعرف
شو الكتاب بس كنت افتح الكتاب اجلس مكان
اللي هو يبتدي فيه يؤلف استخدم المايك
استخدم المسجل يمكن اكون دور انا الشاعر
اكون دور انا المطرب صرت ابنها البيئه
خلاص انا بحس راسي وبعدين كان في بعض
الاوقات كان في وقت المدام بس المفروض اني
اروح انام يعني فكنت اقول لهم معنى حاضر
اجهز لكم اي شيء واا وصلت اي دبوس موجود
في في هذا الغرفه كنت انا اعرف كان اي
شغله يحتاجها والدي من هذا المكان كتاب
دفتر دبوس شريط كذا كذا سليمان انا اذكر
كان يسموني المسجل
كان يسجل اول شيء يعني يتركها اللحم لاني
يكون هو ينضج ينضجرا فكانت لما يقعد مع
رحمه الله عليه مبارك الحديبي يقول لا لا
مو هذا اللحن اللي انت سامعني اياها
لا خلاص نادو سليمان انت الذاكره
الثاني
ارضيه عظيمه واضافه كبيره وقطع عليك جزء
كبير بالمشوار في الجانب الاخر
لن اعيش في جلباب انه تريد
مسار مختلف في الموسيقى ولا تعتبر نفسك
دكتور امتداد تجربه بخالد غنام الدقيقه
يعني في البدايه همم الموسيقى
بالوالده طبعا ناخذ اي جانب ثاني لان
الجانب هذا هو يمكن حس فيه تعب او في في
مواضع كثيره يعني
وانا مصر لتعليم الموسيقى
فحسيت اني انا ممكن اكمل مسيرته بس بشكل
مختلف وهذا كان يمكن اللي هو اللي طلب مني
ان احنا يعني البيئه الموسيقيه الخليجيه
او الكويتيه بيئه عريقه جدا اذا ما كنت
تحترم هذه الحقب والارث الموجود لان تكون
موسيقي يعني جاهز او الولد حد يحترم حتى
موسيقته انت عملت انك تكون امتداد وعملت
انك انت ايضا تاخذها الى مدى ابعد
لانه كان هو كل اللي قدمها والدي او كل
الفنانين الموجودين عم يقولوا للهويه او
المحيط فيهم يعني ما تتعدى الخليج والوطن
العربي انا كان حلمي كيف اني استخرج هذه
الفنون او هذه الحضاره واعمل ثقافه
موسيقيه جديده
واخص يعني استخرج وجدان هذا الشعب الخليجي
الى العالميه درس في المعهد العالي في
الموسيقى
دخلت بمحد العالي في 86 كانت في
الدبلومترات
دبلوم موسيقيه اللي هي الثانويه العامه
تعتبر الدبلومات ما يعادل ثانويه العامه
وبعدها البكالوريوس تخصصت في التاليف
الموسيقي تاليف الموسيقى تاليف الموسيقى
الغربيه
حديثه لالحان مارونيه للحان مارونيه
[موسيقى]
بالضبط والاخواننا مثل ما يقولون بشكل
بسيط يعني كانها الطبع ديني بس حالها
هالكلمات في العالم يمكن في في بعض
الجامعات في العالم لها طابع ديني معين او
كذا شنو سويت في الصياغه الحديثه العامه
طبعا انا كانت في همم احد همم
يعني المواد العلميه انك الوقت
طلبوا مني بعض البحوث فانا اذكر همم كان
همم الاب لويس الحاج والبروفيسور الوسحات
توفى رحمه الله عليه همم طلب من كل الطلبه
فقال انت من حضاره مختلفه وبندير مختلفه
والشرط تعمل لي هذا البحث
حسيت كيف انا ما راح اعمل انا هذا البحث
فقلت ونفس الوقت انا كنت لسه جاي وابعرفهم
على الحال يعني منو يعني جايين
وووو والوحيد اللي قبلوني في الجامعه
انت ممكن تكون مع احد الطلبه مع بعض فانتم
تقدمون ثلاثهكم
خلاص احنا راح نكتبك معانا نكتب اسمك انك
بدون جهد قلت لهم خلوني
قولوا يوم على ذكره
انظروا شمسا ليلا
طويل انظروا لو منعاه ذكره دخيل
شمسا
ليلا طويل اسال
[موسيقى]
وا الطين حتى
اسالوا شيخ الطريق
عملت البحث بعد اسبوع بالضبط هو ندى
البنات بنت بنت داليا سليمان قال انا عارف
هذه البنت الاولى والثانيه مش هم اللي
عاملين البحث لان هذا اللي طلبته من زمان
انت من
وانا في ذاك الوقت يعني كانوا حاضرين مني
في الجامعه بصراحه مش عارف
فكره
المروريه بشكل مختلف
هذا جاي شخص مختلف
علوم موسيقيه ودرس التاليف انا جايك
بالضبط
[موسيقى]
احنا عندنا الموسيقى في الكويت من رياض
الاطفال وبعدين انا دارس الدبلومه
والبكالوريوس موسيقي فانت تقول لي حرام
احنا مش يعني مش من هالدرجه في الانفتاح
مختلف عن كذا فاحنا ناخذها من ناحيه
التربويه والوطنيه وجوز الثقافيه
فعملت هذا البحث هو اللي قال لي ممكن
تعملي هذا العمل لايف على حب كل اللي
بالجامعه يعني يسمعوا افكارك فعملت اول
كونسرت حفل اسمع صدى الاجراس
فتحوا لي تقريبا كل كتبهم ومكاتبهم اني
انا ممكن
يعني حتى هو كان يعني اللي سالني عليه كيف
تنظم
وانا بين السطور يعني حتى انا بقول لما
اسمع ان كانت في الكنيسه يهمني اني انا
اكتب التاثير الكامل
وكيف مسموع في دراستي
المارونيه في الموسيقى عموما فيها بعض
النظريات الاساسيه
النظريات طبعا غير نظريه التاليف
مؤلفات وفي ناس
لاصق الالوان او تناسق الاصوات
او التعدد الخطوط من ناحيه الافقيه عندنا
خطين الفكره اللي انا قدمتها في هذه
ماجستير عملت نسيج ماروني يعني هو الانسجه
اثنين في العالم اثنين
هارموني وكنتربوينت جيت انا عملت فكره
اسمها نسيج الماروني النسيج الماروني كانت
فكرتها اني انا اقدم هذه النظريه ممكن لي
اي شعب والشرط مختصره للمواعده فكان
البروفيسور هل كان الفكره هذه جدا يعني
مناسبه بس اذا انت قدمت لي اي عرسك ما راح
نحس انه
فخليها لنا والدكتوراه ما عندي انا دكتور
دكتور
عرفت اني انا اللي قاعد اشتغل فيه شيء جدا
مهم اللي هو حوار الحضارات التقاء
الحضارات كان ذلك الوقت في 98 اللي انا
اخذت الماجستير كان بعد مو متروك حتى في
الخليج الحوار بين الاديان نبذ العنصريه
يعني في المسلك الصحيح اني انا كيف يعني
موسيقى او يعني همم
تلتقي في الحضارات المختلفه
ويكون فيها حتى وجدان مجتمعي يعني كيف
تبني الموسيقى
استطعت ان تلملم مصادر الموسيقى مسارات
الموسيقى في المنطقه هذا كان اول البوم
يمكن همم في 96 حاولت بعدها اخذ
احصل لرعايات من ثانيه ما حصلت لي بس اول
اول البوم وبعت يمكن في اكثر من ثلاث
300,000 يمكن
حصل على الانتشار انتشار
الاعمال يعني على خلاف ما يقال انها غير
جماهيريه قال جمال طبعا صار الشاعر يحتاج
موسيقى
حتى في بدايته يمكن انا اول ما همم الف
مسيره
بعض كبار يتكلمون
والده الفنان الكبير وهو
بنروحه بتهوفن قلت يا عمي يا ليتني
هذا النمط يعني مستغرب غير مقبول غير
مفهوم في المنطقه نمط المؤلف الاوركسترالي
الموسيقي الذي يؤلف الموسيقى فقط بعيدا عن
الاغنيه والكلمات هو هو يمكن هو الانسان
بسيط يعني هو ما عنده حلم بثقافه بس ما
يعرف ان ان هي الموسيقى هي الوجود وهي
الخلود في في اعمال معينه وشكل معين هي
اللي تخلد الفنان
دائما نقول الموسيقى في الكويت ولا في
الخليج جات من مصادر ثانيه من بلاد فارس
توصيف دقيق دكتور شو مصادر الموسيقى في
المنطقه
احنا يمكن في دول الخليج عموما احنا الدول
لم تمس لا عندنا
يعني
ما في اي اي يعني
اي دول او اي تدخل عاد لا بالانجليزي ولا
من اوروبا احنا ضلينا في بدايتنا وبحرنا
مصعد الرزقنا بشكل بسيط الا يمكن سنه 50
في القرن الفهد ما ما تغير شيء فينا ولا
هتغير حتى شكلها تاثرنا طبعا تاثر احنا
مثلا اذا كنا رحنا عن طريق البحر نتاثر في
كل الدول طبعا احنا اذا رجعنا للصناعه
الموسيقيه احنا ما عندنا صناعه اذا يعني
حتى الربابه اول ما عندنا خشب اسنان حتى
نستحب هذه الربابه مثلا من بلاد الشام
ممكن نستحب العود من بلاد الشام بس احنا
عزفناه بشكلنا بلغتنا بلهجاتنا ليس دقيقه
من بلاد فارس ولله
ابدا اولا ما زال الكلمه خليجيه مثل ما هي
يعني لو تلاحظ ان في كل دوله خليجيه ما
زعلت لها الاغنيه
ممكن نتشابه بالفنون ان كانت سامري او بعض
الفنون البحر او حته في العارضه او الرزفه
حتى التسميات غريبه عن بعض بس ما صارت كل
دوله بلهجتها وبشكلها موجود دكتور تم
القضايا كثيره
تتعلق باهتمامك تتعلق بهذا العالم
وبالتعقيدات المرتبطه تواجه الموسيقى
والمؤلف الموسيقي لكن اودنا نختم هذا
الجزء بعمل تشعر انه قريب جدا من من
سليمان ويعبر عن الفكره التي يريد ان يصل
لها سليمان او المنشغل فيها بشكل كبير
بصراحه مش قضيه واحده يمكن في بدايته يعني
يمكن مؤلف بدايه 92
بدايه تاليفي
يمكن الالحان ما بينتهي يمكن الا بعد من
ثلاث اربع سنوات بس كم ملحن كمؤلف بحب
ابيت نكون مؤلف
الموسيقي بشكل مختلف يمكن في الخليج ما
كان في ذلك الوقت وحتى البومه الاول الامل
او سحر يمكن انا اول البوم خليجي كمؤلف
خليجي ما في حته يمكن
الاعمال اللي انا قدمته لازم يكون فيها
قضايا كانت اهم قضيه في ذاك الوقت كان
الاحتلال وقدمت عليها موسيقات كثيره
قدمتها الاسرى قدمت له الشهداء ومنها السي
دي اللي حضرتك ذكرتها رد الحياه قالت لي
ست احنا يعني من بعد الغزو همم كان في 650
شخص راح وما رجع اسره
وبعدين عرفنا انها جاره همنا شهداء في ذاك
الوقت اشتغل انا عليهم واشتغل على قضيتهم
مهمه جدا
وبعدها عملت افكار كثيره من من اعمال من
اعمال اخر اعمال انا قدمتها يعني اوركسترا
عليه
كان في سنه 20 بالضبط
وهذا الفكره المغايره يعني او كانت يعني
مصادفه ان هي بدايه حلمي اني اكون اكتب
الفنانه المبدع همم محمد السنوسي كان من
احد مخرجين ومنتجين فيلم الرساله الفيلم
الكبير الفيلم
الكاسات فتحت هذه الاسطوانه
فشلت ال ال ال المؤلف موريس جار
وفي صوره مهمه ال ال الاوركسترا
ونفس الوقت السكرين
والاوركسترا تحت الصفر فهي الي يمكن الحمد
الهمتني قبل الان هي كانت صغيره يعني في
بدايه التكوير
اني انا حاولت يعني بين الافلام القديمه
دايما على احضر كل اللي يعني يا اقراء
عرفت ان في فيلم في 62
للمخرج محمد اوسيم وبطوله الفنان عبد
الحسين عبد الرضا رحمه الله
والفنان خالد النفيسي رحمه الله عليهم
بالكتابه همم الفنان همم عبد الامير عيسى
ابن الامير تركي احسن عبد الامير
ويتكلم عن العاصفه وكانه يتكلم عن وقتنا
الحاليه
فحاولت اني احضر هذا الفيلم وكيف انا
استثمر الان وو يعني اعطيه نروح الجديده
اللي احيائها من اول وجديد كان هذا العمل
اركسترالي
العاصفه نسمع جزء منها
[موسيقى]
حياك الله دكتور الله يسلمك الاجواء لطيفه
لكن ابنائها المنطقه يتحملون يعني مهما
كانت قساوه
الحراره او شده البروده حتى
السفينتي
وابنه كمان كمان
هذه
الوظائفكم في البيئه بشكل كبير جدا
بيئه جدا انا اعتقد حتى والدي يقول انا
كان وهو صغير يمكن في جارته
يعني كانت من من الباديه
وحفظ اشياء كثيره منها من اهازيج واعمال
وهي الى الان في ذاكرته كنت اول موسيقي
خليجي يقدم عرضا في دار الاوبرا المصريه
[موسيقى]
فكانت الفكره كيف انا اقدم عمل في القاهره
وسنه 2000 نفس الوقت عندنا شيء مهم اللي
هو الاسرى وانا مهم عندي اي عمل قدمه يكون
فيه فكره وفي رساله نفس الوقت قدمت انا من
اهم الاعمال اللي ذاك الوقت قدمت مقطوعه
اسمها قد قادروها
قادروا البلاد
وبعض القطع همم الموسيقيه هي عباره عن 11
قطعه مصريه يهمني في هذا المقطوعه اهم
قطعه في كانت اللي هي مصر اهرامات من
الاحرار
كنت حاب اقدم اهداء قطعه موسيقيه لمصر
في تحرير الكويت
وفيها رساله مهمه في هذا القطعه الموسيقيه
طبعا كلمه مصر
محمد عبد الوهاب مصر العمال
لقيت لي قصيده كاتبها رحمه الله
في كتابه
المعجم الجراح
كاتب عن مصر وهو عنوان قصيدته اسمها مصر
اهرامات
في بدايه القصيده مكتوب مصر التي
علمتنا القوميه
هذه الفكره اللي انا ممكن اخترق هذا الشعب
في كلمات مهمه جدا
[موسيقى]
الدكتور سليمان
اركسترالي لافت في في دار الاوبرا المصريه
انت ايضا التكات تكون الوحيد الذي ينبغي
لهذه المهمه المساله
اركستراليه وتقديم مقطوعات موسيقيه من هذه
الزاويه تبدو الموسيقى اشكاليه فهمنا
للموسيقى في المنطقه في الكويت وفي الخليج
بشكل عام
تقديرنا لها يبدو يبدو هناك اشكاليه في
هذه المساله احنا اعتدنا على مساله
الالحان والاغاني والطرب والنظر للموسيقى
ك حال الترفيه لكنك تسير في مسار اخر
النظر للموسيقى كعالم مستقل هل هذا الدقيق
احنا بنتكلم عن الموسيقى هي اللغه
العالميه او الغي ال ال الموسيقى للتخاطب
بنت خاطب مع كل العالم او كل بلدان
المتحضره يعني صعب انك تقلقها او محتاج
انها تاثر وتتاثر فاعتقد الموسيقى كذلك
همم عندنا يعني محصول كبير من افكار ومن
ومن تراث ومن ارث بحاجه الى الى تخاطب مع
العالم الى الان اعتقد العالم ينظر لنا
بشكل مختلف بسيط الى الان يشوفونا يعني
مو عارف ان احنا اساسا ان احنا عندنا
معاناه يعني حتى اغلب فنون فنون التراثيه
كلام المعاناه اذا كان في البحر او من
الباديه همم هو مع تقديم لما يشوفوا لنا
في الخارج في سيارات فارعها او هذا هو هذا
الشكل الخليجي لا الخليجي من 70 سنه يمكن
كان بسيط جدا يعني يمكن حتى اللباس
فكيف نتخاطب في ان هو هو يعني بحاجه الى
هذا الارث ان تشكله بتشكيل جديد
وينسق بشكل عالمي يعني بس دكتور هذه يعني
اذا اردنا ان يحترمنا الاخر او ينظر لنا
كحاله حضاريه وثقافيه علينا ان نفعل نحن
ذلك جاء انفسنا هل تعتقد انه احنا دولا
يعني حكومات ومجتمعات ننظر بتقدير عالي
للموسيقى
كما تقدمها انا اعتقد هي مسؤوليه كبيره
امام يعني كل الجهات الاعلاميه والثقافيه
في كل بلدان الخليج انا هي من الخليج لان
احنا اللي ما زلزلنا يعني الى الان لم
يؤثر
قدم الكثير في في المنطقه والى الان في كل
دور العرض العالميه مالنا وجود تقريبا
بشكل مؤثر الى الان بشكل بسيط جدا في
الكويت انشئت دار اوبرا مؤخرا كم عمرها
من حسن حظي اني انا كان في 2006 صدر قرار
في ذاك الوقت في ديوان الاميري كان الوقت
شيخ ناصر صباح الاحمد
واختار مجموعه من الفنانين مع اني انا كنت
اول يعني شخص عزفت في دار اوبرا في ذاك
الوقت في سنه
استشاري فيها وقدمت فكره دار الاوبرا وهمم
وليش يكون عندنا دار اوبرا حتى في الخليج
كلها
دار الاوبرا كل دول العالم هو يعني سنويا
كل دوله تقدم انتاجها الوطني والثقافي ليس
للترفيه فقط ان تحاق العالم او تحاكي حتى
داخليابها سياسيا ثقافيه افكارها احلامها
همم مستقبلها هذا للاسف احنا الى الان
مفكرين انه دار الاوبرا هي عباره عن
دكتور سليمان
لا ابدا احنا اذا احنا رجعنا حق اسماء
الموسيقي الامم اللي في الخليج كلها
تقريبا متشابه من ناحيه الظروف يعني مثلا
كلمه هارموني هي تتناسق تناسق
نحن في ارسنال الشعبي عندنا
يعني هم ناس فنانين شعبيين
في الوقت الاهات او تسمع حتى ايقاعاتنا
الشعبيه كلها عباره عن كاليفورنيا او تعدد
الخطوط هي موجوده
كيف هل الناس هذه المجموعه عندها هذا
الارز اللي غير عادي ونفس الوقت على حضرتك
ان احنا شعب لم يستعمل
ولم نتاثر في اي استعمار يعني كانها ارض
بكر لم لم تصلها تاثيرات ضد غير طبيعتها
الى الان مازلنا فالفكره ان ان
نتناول عناصر جديده ان نتخاطب معنا العالم
هذه ضروره هي حاله الكمبيوتر
بحاجه الى وسائل كثيره
كملت وطلعت الاوبرا وانت كنت من المؤسسين
او من الاشخاص الذين يتراسوا لجان ان شاء
الله بس لما طلعت
النظر
صار في شركه اخذت هذا المكان فما كانت هذه
الفكره في البدايه وبعدين كان ضروري انشاء
اوركسترا كويتي من من احنا عندنا
الموسيقيه وفي اللي هي التطبيقي في كليه
الموسيقى فكان في تجارب في كل الدول
العالم
من الخليج الكوليستورد فرق موسيقيه همم في
همم يعني عندنا تجربه العمانيه سلطنه عمان
تجربه فريده ان اخذت من ابنائها
يعني اللي هي البراعم الصغيره وانشات
وانشات كانت ممتازه هذه الفكر الصحيح
نفس الوقت احنا في المعهد العالي في
المسيحيه احنا عندنا احد اللي هي الدراسات
هو من الثانويه العامه فمعنات عندنا ثمان
سنوات اربع سنوات واربع سنوات المكلاوي بس
من 72 هذه في الوقت الجزء الاول الجزء
الاول نعم ثمان سنوات من 72 سنوات افترض
احنا عندنا اكثر من اوركسره عالميه احنا
تاخرنا تاخرنا ليش بشروط اعتقد في مسؤولين
يعني اللي انشاؤه المعاهد المصريه كان
عندهم ايمان كبير بالفنون والتراث
مثل ما كانت الفنون عموما في في الكويت
عندهم ايمان كبير الان قل احس انها
تتولى
اذا مسؤولك ان كان وزير او كان مسؤول
الاكبر ضعيف سياسيا خلاص تعتقد انه ما في
ايمان حالي لدى لدى اجهزه الدوله
بالموسيقى من هذه الزاويه التي تتحدث عنها
حتى لو ما اعتقد يفترض ان هم كمان لان هذه
حاله او او الان من الاساسيات والان بحاجه
الدوله
ارجع مره ثانيه ما تقدر تكون حضاريه اذا
احنا ما نتخاطب معنا العالم
وليس الموسيقى فقط للترفيه الموسيقى ليس
للترفيه ولا ان الجمهور يرجع او يحضر يقول
ايه ست ايه لا لا هذه مو مو هذا الموسيقى
او انشات دار الاوبرا لهذا الموضوع يفترض
يكون فيه فرق قوميه تحكي تراثها تحت
التراثها نتحاكى مع العالم نتخاطب مع
العالم لنا افكارنا حتى مثلا الان كل
الاعياد الوطنيه اطفال في السنه
افترض الان حتى الكبار عندهم فكر معين
يقدمونه للدوله او خارج الدوله
وانا يعني اكون انه بيت الموسيقى
شفوي الذي يمارس
صوتيا الى شيء مكتوب يمكن ان ان يقرا وان
ينقل من جيل الى جيل وان ينقل من ثقافه
الى ثقافه صحيح الى اي مدى يعني قطعت
مشوار او قطعت شوط في هذا انا اعتقد الى
الان يعني صار في شبيه بمعنى قدمته وانا
هذا بالنسبه لنجاح لما نقدم سيلين موسيقى
وغيري بعدي يقدم سليم موسيقى او يعمل
مؤلفات موسيقيه معناتها
العنوان بحكي كان البناء المعاصر كويتيه
البناء المعاصر احنا في الكويت اول مؤلف
كويتي في ذاك الوقت
عندنا عبد الله الفرج رحمه الله عليه اللي
عاش في الهند عاش في الهند
هو مؤلف موسيقي وبعدها طبعا عنده
يعني طلبتها اللي تعلم الموسيقى من من منه
ومن افكارك
كل مؤلف فيهم عمل بناء يعني بس استدرك مع
الدكتور منه اهم الاسماء بعد عبد الله
الفرج عبد الله الفرج اذا كان المؤلفين او
ملحنين عندنا عبد الله
الفرج ابو الموسيقى
هي الفنون الخليجيه عموما ما كانت
الموسيقى
ان كانت اذا كانت صاحب البحر اغاني البحر
كانت عباره عن اغاني عامر
وليس اغاني
كان مرتبط بالمهن سواء في البناء ولا في
السفينه ولا في الغوص او حتى كان في
الصحراء
الا كانت الا بعض المناسبات طبعا
المناسبات الزواج ما الزواج او الافراح
الاسماء المهم احنا عندنا يوسف طبعا خالد
البكر
[موسيقى]
هو من سجل لنا تقريبا اكثر من
1943 سجل الكاميرا رحمه الله عليه الشيخ
مع المؤرخ احمد الرومي
فهو اللي سجل الاعمال فهي الان هي افضل
وثيقه بالنسبه للكويت او عمرهم الخليج هذه
الالحان بعدها طبعا الفنان عبد الله فضاله
بعدها الفنان عبد اللطيف كويتي بعدين خلاص
جينا مرحله ثانيه لها مرحله التطوير
الفنان السعودي الراشد رحمه الله عليك
الفنان احمد باقر يوسف الدوخي دكتور
للموسيقى في الخليل
في العلوم الموسيقى
[موسيقى]
العربيه ان ان تراثنا وارثنا وحضارتنا لم
تدون يبدو ان هذه ايضا تواجهنا في
الموسيقى همم استعراضك لهذا التاريخ ما
الذي دون منها يعني ما الذي
تم تحويله الى ماده همم
مجاوره او مدونه طبعا حتى الكتب قليله
اللي كتبت احنا عندنا مثل الكتاب وكان
دراسه في العلوم الموسيقيه للدكتور يوسف
الدوخي كانت عندنا البحري وغناء الخليج
عموما وفي همم كذلك كتاب معنا صغير ما كان
كبير بس كان مهم الاستاذ احمد علي وفي كتب
ومحاضرات اخذناهم الديدان هي جدا مهمه
لانه كتب هي عباره عن اعمال يعني
نظريات كتبت ونفس وقته صاحبها اعمال عمليه
قدمها
احنا قدمناها في الحلقه الماضيه كتابتها
الايقاعات الشعبيه طبعا
نظريه مكتوبه فقط من غير ما يكون معموله
بشكل عملي لكن الان لدينا شيء مكتوب في
الموسيقى الخليجيه همم يعني جانب كبير منا
مكتوب صعب يعني او مدوفي في مثل فنان
الشاعر طلال السعيد كتب عن الباديه في كتب
طبعا موجوده بس انت تتكلم عن التدوين
الموسيقي ان تدوين الموسيقي يعني احنا
عندنا كثير سعيد دكتور الان في معهد الالف
الموسيقيه في مجموعه كبيره قدموا من
الرسائل ماجسترات والدكتورات والدكتورات
في العلوم الموسيقيه بس هل كلها همم يعني
بشكل نستفيد منها فنيه ونظريه
وحتى من ناحيه القواعد صعب
في الكويت كان فيها الصناعات صناعه
موسيقيه لكنها تراجعات او راحت راح
يعني اختلف الظروف اختلفت حتى الاغاني
وحتى الموسيقى الان اختلفت مع الظروف انت
عارف كل حقبه حتى حتى كل شكل يعني بالاول
مثلا حتى القصايد اولا القصيده يعني كان
يتغزل في وحده لابسه مثل البرجر والشيله
الان القصيده اختلفت الكلام اختلف في
الارض
راجعون
على كل دول الخليج في الوقت اللي تقدمت
فيه صار فيه انفتاح في دول الخليج سواء في
السعوديه في قطر في الامارات
حالتها محافظه اكتر كانت الكويت منفتح
اكثر من المحيط لانه حدث شيء اعتقد
الان مش صاير مثلا صار كل شيء تجاري
ففرحنا عن معنى الكلمه الاوبرا بشكل
الصحيح يعني الاوبرا شو المقصود فيها
الدكتور بشكل بشكل يعني مبسط خلينا نفهمها
العمل الكبير العمل الكبير اللي يكون فيه
كلمه ولحن وموسيقى وعازفين وديكور
وسيناريو وكرال وراقصين وازياء
يعني هذه العمل الكبير في الكويت
يمكن في بعض الدول تتقدم بس عندنا اعمال
كبرى
يعني نفس المبنى احنا مبادئ فقط هذه يمكن
الفكره اللي اللي اللي يعني كانوا يسموني
كان مسرح مسرح مثل جابر الاحمد انا اصريتي
يسمونه دار الاوبرا
قلت لهم لان احنا اول الدول يعني عمو ممكن
في الخليج او العالم العربي كنا عندنا شيء
اسمه اوبريت اوبريت طبعا مصغر من الاوبرا
كلمه اوبريت
فاغلب اعمالنا الغنائيه يمكن كانت عباره
عن ازياء وراقص وكرار ومطربين وكذا كذا
نفس الفكره بس
بعدنا بعد فيش في نقص
ارجع مره ثانيه في ايمان
في الخليل
[موسيقى]
لكن ما في اهتمام حقيقي بالانسان مثل ما
تقول انه الموسيقى
ثقافه وسيله تواصل ما في ادراك لهذا الامر
ولا ولا يوجد رغبه حتى يعني
تفكر انه يكون عندها منتج ثانويه ثقافي
وطني كل دوله خليجيه يعني وبس يلا قبل
اسبوع او شهر يلا قبل العيد الوطني العالم
[موسيقى]
يحزنني مثلا
عندنا اول مؤسسات خليجيه من معاهم معاهد
الان متطورت
يعني ازعل من
موسيقتنا كانت في الستينيات والثمار
سبعينيات والثمانينات وبدايه 90 كانت
ما كانت شيء كبير حتى المستوى الدراما
الان
اكبر من هذا الحلم في امل
طبعا في امل بس بلا ايمان ايمان ومسؤوليه
كبيره جدا دكتور انا لدي شخصيا حقيقه
الايمان بالموسيقى كحاله ثقافيه
واعتقد انه ايضا صحفيا هذه الرساله لانه
ساهم معه مع المثقفين الملتزمين من امثالك
في ايصال هذه الرساله كانت حلقه حلقتين
حول الموسيقى حول حول ربما اعمال
الاستثنائيه في الموسيقى هنا في الخليج مع
الدكتور سليمان قبل ذلك معه سعد الغامدي
الفني الطويل انا شاكره مقدر لك على لطفك
وعلى اتاحتك الفرصه لنا امنياتنا ان تتحقق
امنياتكم ايضا كمثقه فينا وكمالفينها
موسيقي شكرا جزيلا شكرا لكم
الله يبارك فيك
الشكر ما وصل لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على طيب
المتابعه في الحلقات الاخرى انتم بخير في
امان الله
اعتقد التاريخ الطويل اللي قدمته في
التراب الخليجي
انت اصبحت رمز من الرموز المهمه في هذه
البلاد
والارض الذي حفظته لنا اعتقد هو
المستقبلنا
وحاضرنا راح يكون اشكرك
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
تعلمت في يعني في ارتك وبيتك وحضنك
اشكرك في يعني في اعماق قلبي بصراحه